foreign
[Music]
Wednesdays for our members block portion
of the show I answer emails from
listeners looking for advice and I also
sometimes issue corrections to the bad
advice offered by people on other forms
especially uh Tick Tock and the bad
advice videos are curated by my producer
McKenna and sent to me at which point I
uh go through them all and that's when I
become depressed and disgusted and the
light inside me dies a little more but
at least it makes good content and
that's how the creative process works
but yesterday uh I was sent one bad
advice video that is so bad in which I
found so viscerally abhorrent and
repulsive that it immediately graduated
from Members Blackwater to the Daily
cancellation this of course is the
greatest honor I can bestow on a
terrible person and we have a very
terrible person for today's second
Jessica Ashley bills herself as a
divorce coach this is apparently an
actual industry that exists in our
country after a brief Google search I
discovered there are many divorce
coaches and divorce Consultants charging
exorbitant hourly rates to encourage and
facilitate the dissolution of marriages
um divorce coaches
should not be confused with divorce
lawyers these are two different species
of blood sucking parasites think of one
as kind of like a deer tick and the
other is a dog tick and even the ticks
have ticks as there are now many pricey
online certification programs offered
for those who want to become certified
in the field of divorce coaching so if
you wish to be a certified a certifier
of a certified divorce coach then you
get then you have to do that if you want
to be a certifier of people who are
certifying divorce coaches there are
probably different programs for that
and if you want to coach people who
certify the people who certify the
people who are divorce coaches again
there is I assume a program for that one
thing we've learned about the modern
modern culture is that for every evil
for every brand of misery there are a
million vultures circling looking for a
way to make a fast Buck on someone
else's poor life choices in fact there
is so much misery and so many soulless
profiteers trying to monetize it that it
becomes a kind of parasitic infinite
regress
and somewhere in this garbage heap lies
Jessica Ashley who offers three-month
and six-month divorce subscription
Services uh she's also on call by the
way ready for her phone or FaceTime
consultations for anyone desperate and
stupid enough to pay the money for it
and sorry fellas I got to tell you she
does stipulate that she is a divorce
coach for moms specifically her website
tagline is a mom's best girlfriend in
divorce
though I strongly suspect that the
market for divorce coaches consists
almost entirely of women anyway it's
like if the Cupcake Wine Company
stipulated that it was just for women
you know it's already kind of implied by
the nature of the product
but uh Jessica has developed a
relatively sizable social media
following consisting entirely of the
sorts of women who have been you know
would have been probably tried and
convicted of Witchcraft if they'd been
born in a different era uh these are
women who who can't get enough of this
kind of stuff listen
the very best piece of advice I've ever
received about divorce came in the early
days of my own divorce from a friend
who'd never been divorced and in fact
wasn't even married at the time she said
something so powerful really got in
there and it still Rings true today and
I share it with my divorce coaching
clients often here's the best piece of
divorce advice I've ever heard your life
is bigger than one man let's extend it
your life is bigger than one
relationship one marriage One Moment In
Time even if that relationship comes
with good intentions and Oodles of love
and Big Dreams in a home and kids and
memories and vacations what happens if
you release your grasp that this
relationship defines the whole of you
and the whole of your life to see what
could come next what is happening now
there was a time before this
relationship you are heading into the
next part what are the possibilities
that extend far beyond this one person
now the people in the comments section
are absolutely Blown Away by these
platitudes that Jessica plagiarized from
the slogans on inspirational keychains
at a gift shop somewhere she's like some
kind of feminist bumper sticker and yet
many of the commenters claimed that they
were reduced to Tears by Jessica's
recitation of modernist cliches one
woman said that the video had saved her
life
which is which is like having your life
saved by a fortune cookie worst of all
the cliches aren't true because if you
are betraying your vows and dismantling
your marriage and running out on your
husband and hurting your children in
pursuit of your own personal happiness
you are not bigger than the moment um
there are moments in life that make us
who we are moments that tell us and tell
the world
who we really are and if you're
following Jessica Ashley's advice then
you will answer that moment by
announcing yourself to be a disloyal
self-centered shallow superficial
narcissist you were not bigger than the
moment you are defined by it the whole
point of marriage is that two become one
and when you say I do to your spouse you
are entering into something that is
bigger than you and from this Union
Springs a family and children and a
whole life that you could never live on
your own you're not bigger than that
if you shrink away from that commitment
that that that's uh that sacred
institution that you've entered into
it's not because you're bigger than it
but because you are smaller than it you
are too small too Hollow to grasp the
happiness that can be found in loyalty
and Fidelity to your family
in the same way if you visit the Sistine
Chapel and you find that you're bored or
unimpressed by the site it's not because
you're too significant or too big to
appreciate it right that's because
you're you're such a small-minded
brain-dead idiot that you can't
recognize Beauty when you're standing in
his presence
that's why none of the divorced cat
ladies who pay Jessica for consultations
will go on to achieve great things or
contribute to the world in any important
way
none of them will
now they say that they're getting
they're divorced and they're free now
and they can go out into the world and
do all these impressive things I'm not
going to do anything instead they'll
wind up dating a bunch of pathetic men
desperate enough to see them as romantic
options and they'll argue with their
ex-husbands and they'll watch a lot of
TV and they'll be promoted to middle
management and they'll make you know 140
000 a year and they'll feel very
accomplished and they'll spend their
money on consumer products and cat food
and they'll tell themselves a story
about the journey they've been on but
that Journey will be about as
interesting and unique as a Hallmark
greeting card less interesting actually
because at least a Hallmark card is
something that you buy to Express
gratitude towards some other person in
your life
but the women who listen to Jessica
Ashley are far more focused on
expressing gratitude towards themselves
they are collapsing into themselves
sucked into the Vortex of their own egos
the human equivalent of dying Stars
slowly evolving into black holes
except that you know entire galaxies
really do revolve around actual black
holes in the case of these women that's
how they see themselves but it's not the
reality
now Jessica has more wisdom to offer
though in another video she tries to
explain why men might change during the
course of a marriage here's her Theory
have you ever asked why your husband is
radically changed why he seems like a
completely different person than he was
in the early days of marriage before
kids or maybe even before you got
married have you look back over the last
few years with a fine tooth comb and
everything said and done looking for the
perfect clue an incident or event that
will help bring rationale to why he has
turned so hateful in his words in action
When you entered into this Union with
such love have you desperately sought
out the perfect things for you to say or
do that will get this marriage back on
track that will get him back on track
that will maybe be the Cure marriage
counseling or Couples Retreat or maybe a
change in meds now certainly trauma
grief mental health issues illness
injury so many things can cause us to be
an acts totally differently but
sometimes people's masks get too heavy
and they fall off and they reveal who
they really are
now sure okay that might be true in some
cases there are some men who essentially
dupe their wives into marriage
sociopaths Who hide their true nature
their true selves uh there are women who
do this also you know that that can
happen in a marriage but if you're a
woman
whose husband seems to have grown
miserable and angry during the course of
your marriage
you should also consider
the very real possibility that he has
become that sort of man
in response to the sort of woman you are
um you should at least consider that
possibility that is a that is a
potential
explanation that you must take into
account
and if you're the sort of woman who is
inclined to seek counsel from a cliche
spewing divorce coach on Tick Tock it
seems rather likely that you're
miserable angry quote hateful husband
has been broken down by years spent
trying to please these shallow
egotistical when she married again I'm
obviously not saying this is always the
case I'm simply saying that it's a
possibility you have to take into
consideration
because as men you know we very much
want our wives to support us to be proud
of us
um we might not express that desire out
loud in fact we probably will never say
that we aren't generally generally very
Adept at vocalizing those kinds of
emotions and desires but when a man
comes home from his from work and you
know his wife gives him a kiss and says
hi honey I'm so glad you're home or you
know when his wife comes up to him at
the blue and says that she's she's proud
of him and grateful how for how hard he
works
um something like that that man will
immediately be on Cloud9 you will feel
appreciated and respected and loved
this is what women need to understand
about men you don't need to give us
very much to make us happy we just need
your affection we and and we'll never
tell you that we'll never verbalize it
but that's what we need that's what we
want we actually want to feel
appreciated and loved
by our wives if you can believe it
that's that's something that men in a
marriage really want
um
let me let me give you let me give you a
secret here's the cheat code this is
what every man wants okay this is this
is how you make him happy
he wants to walk in the door after work
and his children run up to him and say
hi Daddy and they give him a hug and his
wife comes over and smiles and kisses
him dinner's on the stove everyone is
happy and glad to see him I mean and
that's all it really is as simple as
that
that's that's if a man has that he has
almost everything he needs in the world
of course not it can't be like that
every day and every family is different
every situation is different uh it might
be a situation where maybe both spouses
have to work especially in this economy
uh maybe the man Works a different shift
so he's not really coming home at dinner
time anyway my point is simply to convey
to you how easy it is to make a man
happy how simple our desires actually
are
how comparatively little we actually
want
um how love and affection and gratitude
are the things that we really need in
our marriage
so if your husband seems bitter and
angry
you might consider whether you have
given him any of those things
anytime recently or at all
or you could just assume that he's a
sociopathic monster who is wearing a
mask and only let it slip after years of
marriage that could be the case
but if you assume it's the case
there's probably a rather self-serving
reason for that
that's what divorce coach Jessica Ashley
isn't going to tell you and it's why she
is today canceled
[Music]
[Applause]